they bought it did I leave the stove on
oh don't deny it you've loved it
the fourth wall once you break it you
have to buy it movies and TV shows have
been breaking this imaginary wall for
decades including Deadpool She-Hulk the
office House of Cards fleabag and Ferris
Bueller's Day Off a few weeks ago a
friend of mine asked me if I thought
She-Hulk did as good of a job at
breaking the fourth wall as Deadpool and
it got me thinking why do characters
break the fourth wall and how can it be
done correctly
[Music]
first of all we need to know what the
fourth wall is and how someone can break
it the formal definition for the fourth
wall is an invisible imaginary wall that
separates actors from the audience it
gets its name from early stage shows
which started using box sets in the 16th
century with three walls and an
imaginary fourth wall between the
audience and a stage breaking the fourth
wall was originally described as any
time an actor directly referred to the
audience to the play as a play or to the
character's fictionality now however
it's described by any time a character
in a work of fiction does or says
something that reminds you that you're
watching a work of fiction whether it be
winking at the audience making long meta
monologues or giving a lesson on how to
fake being sick to get out of school you
fake a stomach cramp and when you're
bent over moaning and wailing
you lick your palms some people argue
that breaking the fourth wall is lazy
because it takes you out of the story
I'd argue though that if used correctly
it can push you into a film rather than
pulling you out of it fourth wall bricks
can be used for four main purposes
comedy satire to show intimacy or to
invoke fear probably the most common
reason they're used though is comedy
anyway I got places to be a face to fix
and oh bad guys to kill comedic fourth
wall breaks involve the character
stepping out of the film to deliver a
punchline and for comedic purposes
fourth wall breaks have to be somewhat
surprising or they can come off as lazy
in fact too much of a good thing can
actually be a bad thing take some of the
work of Mike Myers for example in the
Austin Powers movies these breaks can
come off as a bit lazy or altogether
unnecessary just enjoy yourself
that goes for you all too
yes in movies like Wayne's World however
the fourth wall breaks seem very
intentional and still surprising
contractor no I will not bow to any
sponsor
it's times like these where one can
recognize the value and breaking the
fourth wall within a comedy and you
can't mention comedic fourth wall breaks
without talking about Mel Brooks his
films displayed the epitome of how to do
a great fourth wall break he even went
so far as to have his characters watch
themselves in the movie
[Music]
finding a creative way to break the
fourth wall and make the audience aware
that they're watching a movie is half
the fun the next most common reason
fourth wall breaks are used is satire
when a filmmaker or writer wants to poke
fun at a genre or topic they can use the
tool of fourth wall breaks to make their
point for example Blazing Saddles use
this device to display the lack of
realism in old western movies satirizing
the fake Romance of the old west which
was really one of the most unromantic
times and places to be alive
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
oftentimes in satirical fourth wall
breaks the characters don't speak
directly to the audience instead they
address the world around them or the
film or TV show they're in they don't
have to speak to the audience because
meta references can have an even greater
effect quick plug if you like what
you're seeing hit that subscribe button
for more videos like this now back to
the video breaking the fourth wall can
also be used to show intimacy it can be
used to show us what characters actually
think or what they want us to believe
they think he's been really nasty what
is that
well the thing that you're doing it's
like you disappear in this scene we not
only get to see what the main character
is actually thinking because of the
fourth wall break but we also get an
understanding that the priest is also
getting to know the main character
better than anyone else in the series
because he too can recognize her
breaking the fourth wall throughout both
seasons of fleabag the main character
has broken the fourth wall a number of
times but only one person has ever
noticed the priest this gives us insight
as to how connected he is to her and how
he's able to break down her outer shell
to see the real her so if used
creatively and thoughtfully these fourth
wall breaks can show us both a
character's true thoughts and their
level of connection to other characters
the last reason to break the fourth wall
is to invoke fear sometimes it can be
used to unsettle the audience or cause
them to feel uncomfortable breaking the
fourth wall like this is one way to
actually push the audience further into
the narrative rather than pulling them
out it makes us feel as if the character
on screen can actually see us and is
speaking directly to us as individuals
rather than reminding us that we're
watching a movie honestly there's almost
nothing scarier than feeling safe and
removed from the villain throughout a
movie and then having that villain look
directly at you
[Music]
at you breaking the fourth wall but we
still haven't discussed how to do it
correctly in other words what makes a
fourth wall break good or even
remarkable well first of all it has to
be thoughtful extreme or controversial
the real question is this
was all this legal
absolutely not fourth wall breaks can't
just be placed anywhere in hopes to cash
the audience off guard they have to be
used thoughtfully and they have to be
very intentional especially if they're
used regularly they should be used
during key moments to pack a punch and
to make that punch really land they
should also be extreme by extreme I
don't necessarily mean that they have to
terrify the audience but they should
elicit a somewhat strong emotional
reaction if they don't then they'll feel
like any other part of the movie and
will likely come off as flat or lazy
lastly good fourth wall breaks have to
be controversial they should be bold or
make a statement this is especially true
if a film rarely breaks the fourth wall
controversial doesn't mean the fourth
wall break has to be crass or rude it
simply means that you're able to get the
audience's attention or give them
something to talk about after the show I
will run this Branch or I will destroy
this Branch or
I don't know something always works out
now let's compare some of the fourth
wall breaks and two recent Marvel
projects She-Hulk and Deadpool when it
comes to these characters I'd say that
each of them breaks the fourth wall for
a different purpose the majority of the
time Deadpool mostly breaks the fourth
wall for comedic purposes while She-Hulk
does so to show intimacy and to tell us
her inner thoughts he doesn't mean that
fourth wall break inside a fourth wall
break that's like 16 walls yeah about
that
um it's true I am a Hulk you might want
to look away for this as you can see
while Deadpool does provide some of his
internal thoughts most of his fourth
wall breaks are made to provide comic
relief She-Hulk on the other hand breaks
the fourth wall mostly to show us what
she's thinking and maybe to provide
comic relief on the side I think when
Deadpool breaks the fourth wall it's
almost always perfectly placed and has
fantastic timing for the purpose these
brakes are trying to achieve they get a
10 out of 10 in my book when She-Hulk
breaks the fourth wall though I don't
necessarily know if they always land
quite as well I think they do a great
job of showing us some of She-Hulk or
Jen's inner dialogue but the comedy
doesn't land nearly as well as Deadpools
you ever see 127 Hours
spoiler alert
but I'll leave it up to you which hero
do you think did it best Deadpool or
She-Hulk
your thoughts in the comment section
below also check out the video on your
screen for some more of my content don't
forget to like And subscribe and thanks
for watching Rocket Riley
[Music]